je me suis débattu une traînée par les
cheveux avec un wenger
voilà il tirait bien sur le coup les
cheveux
voilà il va racheter cuir chevelu c'est
normal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour la canicule frappe et grandes
villes tout le monde cherche un coin
pour se rafraîchir il faut croire que
les parisiens s'étaient passé le mot
pour se retrouver au parc aquatique
aquaboulevard et 11 heures du matin une
foule de franciliens et francilienne en
quête de fraîcheur ou de bronzage à saab
ont des débordements pdi du marron le
complexe a été pris d'assaut et la
fréquence a littéralement explosé
accueillant plus de 4000 personnes en
même temps
[Applaudissements]
soit la capacité maximale on a des
capacités qui sont dictées par la
préfecture de police menée l'hiver à
2500 entrées fmi donc c'est la
fréquentation maximum instantané on peut
aller jusqu'à 5000 5 à peu près suite au
vite on a voulu baisser nos
fréquentations maximum instantanée qui
sont réglementaires évidemment et on est
sur du 4000 donc on a aussi prévu ça
parce que très honnêtement et même si je
suis comme vous un les images peuvent
être surprenante en tout cas c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire en tout état de
cause on avait prévu que ça puisse en
tout cas se passer cette nuit des
audiences n'ont aucun souci moi j'aurais
juste revenir sur un point puisque c'est
vrai qu'on voit regardez c'est facile de
voix tout ce qui ne marche pas mais
c'est bien aussi de voir ce qui marche
ce qui a marché on s'est organisé il ya
eu des systèmes côté mis en place je
vous expliquer par rapport aux revendre
le ticket on a arrêté la tique et riz à
partir de midi on a mis un système de
barriérage en place on a géré aussi un
afflux assez conséquent de différents
endroits que ce soit paris cimino on
avait aussi un phénomène s'aggrave en où
les bases de loisirs ne seront pas
ouvertes en tout cas la partie aquatique
donc on a beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
sont déjà large et sait comment le
ticket est au plus bas au niveau du
plein tarif alors ça m'a dit bon si vous
avez de revendeurs on est à 37 euros
l'entrée puis après on a des journées 1
pas forcément parce que là encore les
soucis des n'ont pas forcément parce
qu'on est aussi sur beaucoup de prêts
billetterie donc c'est d'ici qu'est ce
qu'on va monsieur en avant cet accord
avec des tarifs réduits alors aux
grilles étaient alors vous avez passé
une journée aquaboulevard ce week-end
vous habitez la région parisienne
j'habiterai à livry gargan 93 d'accord
vous étiez avec qui j'étais avec ma
famille vous avez dit que vous avez vécu
l'enfer pas en fait déjà le les bassins
il s'est excusé moi le terme il était
dégueulasse quoi ans quand on est 10
heures centaines dans le dans l'eau l'ol
était trouble pour se laver les pieds
certes comme on a dit il ya le sable
mais en soit on se lave les pieds là
pour aller dans l'eau derrière quoi donc
si l'eau est sale lauda piscine trace à
l'oci donc voilà après aussi je vous
avais parlé des agents de sécurité et là
dessus je veux rebondir parce que oui
c'est vrai mais moi j'ai été témoin de
de virulence envers des des jeunes
justement et j'avoue après je veux pas
blâmer ses agents la qui ont essayé de
faire leur travail au mieux et je pense
qu'ils ont été surtout débordé par par
les événements mais enfin moi j'arrivais
entendu des propos je me suis dit quoi
vous en donne quoi
c'est ouais si j'étais ton père je
trouvais casser la gueule viens là que
je t'attrape vraiment des trucs mais où
là je veux bien croire que à douala moi
je pense que le problème c'est monde
quoi le monde qui avait il y avait sur
place quoi y avait tant de monde parce
qu'à la mairie de paris vous avez une
grève des piscines alors ça paraît
surréaliste ils ont le droit de faire
grève mais depuis plusieurs week-ends
impossible pour les jeunes qui habitent
la banlieue qui sont dans des immeubles
souvent au chaud qui a envie de frais
comme tout le monde ou des familles
impossible d'aller dans les piscines de
paris donc tout le monde va
aquaboulevard c'est plus cher mais au
moins c'est ouvert dont il faut que
cette grève des piscines de paris s'est
immédiatement mais en temps en temps de
canicule soit la technique un vrai
décalage entre les gros titres qu'on a
pu lire dans les médias week-end donc à
l'aquaboulevard violence à la cua ou pas
les images quand on les regarde en fait
oui certes il ya beaucoup de monde mais
il y en a eu de violence il n'ya pas
d'anglais n'y avait rien et j'attends
qu'elle ait des gens qui s'amusent et
tout ça et est exagéré avec les
centaines de messages racistes qui sont
horribles qui a eu son agent sociaux sur
les chaînes youtube sur les articles du
parisien des commentaires qui sont à
vomir et je suis choqué par le nombre de
ses commentaires on ne veut pas que
j'aille aniche 17 euros pour avoir ses
premiers pas je vais être régulée juste
on revient sur des basses et c'est pas
pour réguler c'est les mêmes prix toute
l'année donc y en aura pour réguler le
monde quand il
est accablé parce qu'on va mettre à 45
ou 50 euros bon il ya une chose qui est
simple c'est qu'aujourd'hui on veut
accueillir tout le monde attend que ça
on peut rester tournée du matin au soir
bien voilà on doit payer en deux
périodes bien sûr mais on doit se payer
à manger aussi oui aussi
on va reparler limiter le temps de des
gens parce qu'on a vu ce phénomène aussi
qui a été vraiment où on a des gens
d'habitude pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée c'est trois quatre heures
quelqu'un qui vient froehly maïs il
restera comme une large adore se parera
ya plein de gens qui 20 euros ça va un
roman je trouve que c'est franchement
c'est raisonnable je suis désolé 20
euros c'est raisonnable voilà et vous
vous avez payé 20 euros voilà vous étiez
où vous avez quand vous avez passé une
bonne journée quand même pas du tout
catastrophe à saïda strophes je n'irai
pas jusque là mais j'avoue que ça aurait
été plus agréable avec moi je voulais
c'est payant problème de bayaii
volailles et les piscines qui sont
fermés fois encore
elle a heureusement on sait pas pourquoi
dans un tweet l'attaquant des bleus
explique que les problèmes après l'euro
2000 21 venait des attaques racistes le
concernant et non des simples critiques
sur son penalty manqué qui va être
inexcusable il a passé dans ses mandats
à minimiser le racisme dans sa mire
après l'euro même le parquet de paris
avait lancé une enquête j'ai pris une
seule des phrases qui est immonde à
l'encontre de clients aiment ap après
son tir au but raté contre la suisse je
vous la cites elle est terrible sale
[ __ ] tu mérites de te prendre une
centaine de coups de fouets vous rendez
compte de la violence à ça a été écrit
sur les réseaux qu'il ya même la paix et
le président nigérien sais rien m.ben ap
franchement je trouve qu'il a du mérite
d'avoir continuer en équipe de france
sûre niveau là c'est dégueulasse quand
c'est pas c'est dégueulasse de
répondre à noël la grèce parce que je
suis un 10 ans maintenant ils n'auraient
pas dû l'être il a très bien su le graet
dit une contre vérité et barberger
l'audi que il voulait quitter l'équipe
de france non pas pour des raisons de
racisme et parce qu'il avait raté le
penalty lui remet l'église au milieu du
village en disant non à un moment j'ai
voulu partir parce que je ne supportais
pas le racisme que dans l'ain qui sont
au camp quand monsieur le graet a dit
oui a pas de racisme sur qui on a bien
sûr nazis ment pas y en a dans le
football et personne n'est monté dessus
quasiment pas donc que les journalistes
sportifs mais personne n'est monté
dessus dans le monde du foot pour dire
tu dit que des conneries on en est son
terrain on entend bien que parfois je
dis pas tout le temps parfois c'est trop
on entend des propos racistes ça fait
onze ans on en a ras-le-bol c'est ce
qu'il est très mauvais ah ouais tu es
très mauvais je n'aime pas du tout
j'ai très bien connu avec les girondins
de bordeaux à l'ouest vous tenez
j'ai vu le type que c'était très serré
le triage je suis désolé c'est pas le
tibia donc je demande la démission de
noël le graet très bas après 11 ans à
toutes les conneries qui pense que vous
allez l'obtenir
[Rires]
citoyenne et ben laden le 2 mai
calme-toi les moyens de le gray qui
vient de m'envoyer un message il me dit
je demande la démission
[Rires]
après des bassins sur bombay et une
hygiène qui laisse à désirer
plusieurs actes de violence ont été
constatées et même film et y ai
ras-le-bol joly directeur adjoint des
opérations dacquois boulevard explique
que la situation avait été dans
l'ensemble contrôler non non on n'a que
très peu d'incidents alors aux actions
des personnes non pas du tout on n'a pas
eu d'accident aujourd'hui un autre
témoignage vient remettre en question la
sécurité du parc aquatique c'était moins
c'est alan il raconte avoir été agressée
par plusieurs agents de sécurité lors de
sa visite alors que s'est-il vraiment
passé ce week-end à aquaboulevard ce
soir à l'année sa maman s'exprime dans
tpm alors déjà je vous remercie de la
parole ce soir
moi aussi ça a été invité par sa tante
aquaboulevard parce que c'était
l'anniversaire de son propre fils donc
ils étaient deux mamans monfils et son
cousin et un petit garçon de huit ans
donc déjà c'était une famille c'était
des jeunes quand bien même le contexte
d'accord donc son cousin laquelle vous
avez quel âge il à l'huile à 15 ans et
son coût étant un cousin à 14 ans
[Applaudissements]
alors les maîtres nageurs éclaboussé ont
fait appel à des agents de sécurité
c'est ça moi là monfils n'éclabousse est
pas bon si ce n'est lancée pas de
brassard ils ont pensé qu alan faisait
partie des éclaboussures voilà c'est ça
en fait il ya un jeune qui a un bon
enfant apparemment aussi avec la boue
c'est un maître nageur qui était à côté
de mon fils à ce moment là et quand il
s'est retourné il a vu mon psy sachant
que cette se mettre aux nageurs étaient
déjà en train d'insulter de tous les
noms les enfants donc je pense qu'il
avait perdu son sang froid que je peux
comprendre vu la situation en même temps
c'est dans cette direction que jamais
dans la situation et je vais te [ __ ]
ta mère fils de l'autre comme ça ouais
c'était pas si parce que quand on dit
que les enfants là sont des racailles je
me manquiez la racaille en fait quand
j'entends les les propos qui ont été
tenus sur tous les noms je ne dis c'est
pas moi mais bon il continué à insulter
et laissera proches de moi ont motivé le
frapper vous pouvez lui dit tu vas faire
quoi et lime pouce du coulage de la rose
et moi je suis parti directement un peu
on peut le voir sur la vidéo est
directement dès que super si tout le
monde a commencé à la rose et moi c'est
parce que je voulais pour la situation
se calme alan d'encre par faire des
toboggans et trois agents de sécurité de
récupère alors il le bouscule et le
traînent dans une salle trop vite ils
font courir t'attrape prenant par le
bras ouais il y en a un qui m'a attrapé
par le bras après un est de la sécurité
qui m'a prépare la gorge il m'a soulevé
m'a jeté par terre après j'ai aussi
débattu une traînée par les cheveux avec
un autre gars et ils m'ont ramené vers
une salle ils m'ont dit ce qu'on va voir
tu va voir ce qu'on va te faire tout ça
et l'aide commençaient à me tirer et moi
je m'accrochais à l'ap hm parce que j'ai
cru que ça allait me frapper à mort ou
m'accrocher à la porte n'accueillir le
crij et que j'ai en tout ça et m'écouter
pas s en fout quoi tu disais j'ai 15 ans
j'ai percé j'ai rien fait tout ça existe
et ça et je me prenais des tartes et il
est nominé tard mario way beaucoup et
c'est vraiment des vrais de vrai couac
en pendentif au sol aussi away aussi et
il me moi ils m'ont amené vers la porte
je me suis tenu à l'apport d'une sous
verre les doigts
voila voila mais c'est ça la la la la il
tirait bien sur le coup les cheveux
voilà il arrache le cuir chevelu c'est
normal c'est la procédure
de
passer la procédure apparaît assez la
pause mais il sait ce que jamais à des
jeunes sportifs alors c'est grâce à ça
vous parle simplement de porter plainte
et touba oui mais attention que j'ai
porté plainte à fait prêt fait quoi
j'espère que ça sera pas que la saq je
suis aujourd'hui merci pour trouver les
témoins qui ont été violentés dans cette
salle parce que forcément c'est une
salle du personnel sans caméra mais cas
là où vous êtes tabac c'est ce que dit
la direction tout simplement c'est
qu'elle vous emmène au vestiaire pour
que vous vous rhabiller et que là vous
opposer une résistance au fait d'être
conduit au vestiaire non pas du tout
déjà ils m'ont pris ils m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient qu tu va voir ce qu'on va te
faire dans la salle pouces oms qu'ils
aient moins d'écueils de qui m'ont dit
ça c'est normal que je me des bottes et
là il a déjà il a peur et déjà il est
accompagné c'est un enfant est ce qu'on
lui a demandé quel âge tu en es tu
accompagnes et je veux te sortir doit
quoi boulevard parce que j'estime que tu
as un agitateur je vais aller voir la
personne qui est qui qui est là qui est
responsable
et et dans ce cas là il sort avec la
personne qui l'accompagné elle n'était
même pas prévu vous trouvez ça normal
concrètement moi je veux quand même dire
que moi mon fils je sais qu'il est brisé
son enfance elle est terminée et moi je
suis là pour le défendre je vois là je
déteste j'ai pas envie d'être là mais je
les fais pollution et j'espère que
vraiment je vais avoir des témoignages
des enfants qui ont été violentés dans
cette salle aussi et que mon fils fera
la seule la justice sera faite et que
cet homme là sera puni
et qui pourra pu recommencer aussi
[Musique]
gilles favard était l'invité tp pour
évoquer la prolongation qu'il y en a
marre pjc a très vite dégénéré se
connaissaient déjà depuis un moment mais
n'ont pas résisté à régler leurs comptes
sur le plateau
[Musique]
gmail hervé tu vas tu t'énerves et toi
t'as pas vu tes taillé dans un cachot de
bal musette
java accusés d'avoir produit de fausses
notes de frais ce qui est un délit
monsieur fabas et n'ai jamais fait ça
n'est jamais bidonné vous votre cv il
est totalement faux ça va chose c'est
vrai chez vous sa vie privée sa vraie
tôt car ça va
vos excuses je les attends de pied ferme
alors écoute moi si tu veux pas qu'on
parle de choses qui vont déranger des
gens je vais te parler d'un certain
mariage à cuba de ta part en août a
laissé des gens en plans ou des rentrées
en laissant des quelqu'un avec qui tu
t'es marié à cuba depuis ce que tu as
voulu rentrer dans ses salles à ta bien
fils de l'ouvrier était malade
non mais il faisait il faisait partie tu
l'as dans les années 80 javel et il y
avait des petits arrangements de
rassurer
je ne pouvais pas fils et la mère de ma
fille
tu brûles la mère de sa fille donc tu
vas fermer pagnol qu'est ce que tu as
l'âge et du créateur en touriste à cuba
touristes à cuba gêné pour marier mais
t'es malade
l'élu landes était revenue avec une
femme mais oui ma famille les malades
que tu as un petit peu tête un petit peu
quand on va te dire certaines choses
c'était que tu as laissé que ta plante
et connais pas ce que tu es un planteur
tu sais ce que c'est un plan que c'est
là mais je vais je vais
vivre
non mais c'est pour ça que tu fais ça
lembeye son tintin mais fait mal à des
maladies l'on est malade jour apparaît
la dernière fois tu avais fait illusion
parce que guillaume genton avait donné
trois répliques sinon tu as été
complètement transparent allez je
comprends pourquoi on appelle le spectre
écoute moi mais vous avez vu ce qu'ils
disent et râler on est là pour
manon tu me les brise ok je t'ai dit la
dame sans fils et va rentrer dans la loi
de l'emmerdement maximum et tu veux y
rentrer et tu vas y aller correct de
dire et crois moi tu vas y aller et
d'ipad et je te faire découper en
rondelles oui toujours dit on des choses
qu'ils sont mais bien fait et on va te
manger avec des eaux libres
tu as un rigolo ecoute-moi ernest a
rigolé jamais adressé la parole allemand
40 ans je n'avais jamais vu je
partageais micro aux
escrocs mais c'est toi qui dis
moi les journalistes incompétents qui
ont fait des frais fixes alors
oui
il a fait le parisien l'équipe et le
parisien chaque fois il s'est fait virer
parce qu'il faisait des fausses notes de
frais parce que ce sont aux mères mais
jamais j'ai un ami je vais me rabibocher
avec toi que jamais à baja l'été venu
j'étais venu j'allais venir te serrer la
main je vais essayer quand même
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais que tout le monde a parlé de
cette histoire aujourd'hui c'est le gros
dos du jour
voulait convoieront voir on va on voit
juste l'extrait encore une fois avec
adama vous allez nous dire voilà
elisabeth ce que vous en pensez si vous
regrettez ou si vous voulez précisé bon
allez non elle n'est pas mauvais
mais c'est une très belle femme et je
n'avais pas envie qu'elle donne moi la
soul est effectivement raciale kéké
était une femme très estimable et le
principal reproche que je lui faisais
c'était plutôt sur une autre déclaration
c'était pas du tout il se trouve que
dans toutes ces photos je n'avais vu en
boubou ce qui ne me pose aucun problème
j'ai rien contre les boubous le votre
est très jolie on a déjà parlé un accord
et simplement l'assemblée nationale
n'est pas pour moi un endroit où on doit
être le porte parole de ses origines de
sa propre culture et j'aurais dit
exactement la même chose si un juif
orthodoxe arrivée à l'assemblée
nationale avec soul streible vous savez
le grand show ou et la bretonne en
coiffe bigoudène adama peut-être 7 7 à
10 et à déranger c'est ça on va pas
déranger ça m'attriste ça m'attriste
d'avoir aujourd'hui à répondre un
discours sera la tenue vestimentaire je
pense quand même en france nos anciens
l'ohio a fait chuter notamment cm7 avec
les guerres de religion avec l'édit de
nantes exactement en 1998 quatre
importantes connaître notre histoire et
chaque match et n'a pas quand je fais
des cours historiques mais ça apporte un
moment donné lors qu'on s'exprime on
parle avec instruction les meilleurs
qu'aujourd'hui une femme journaliste qui
a quand même l'habitude de tout ce qui
est liberté finalement corps est bien
présent mais est-ce que je n'ai pas
vraiment allez me dire qu'aujourd'hui on
essaie de résoudre une personne tenue
vestimentaire on lui prête ses
intentions de jacques à venir est tenue
vestimentaire l'assemblée nationale pour
nous présenter sa culture
intellectuellement parlant c'est très
faible elle est par boubou et vous dis
là encore heureux les parents vous l'a
véritablement vous ne pouvez pas cacher
que cette phrase est totalement raciste
elle montre et total elle va vraiment
vraiment votre collation déconner
quelques des noms mais non mais non les
abeilles ll est pas en vue heureusement
déjà à l'époque au bout ça prouve déjà
que vous juger quelqu'un qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas là ce n'est celle en
boubou lui fait un reproche qu'elle n'a
pas fait ou vraiment votre votre génie à
votre déco vous pensez c'est du racisme
et la boue les sommes en jeu leurs
achats fois qu'on dit quelque chose si
vous voulez qu'ils s'éloignent de votre
grande opinion sera-ce y est c'est
l'accusation qui d'ailleurs je vous
signale qu'elle ne le fait plus de mal à
personne parce que vous l'employez tout
le temps c'est à dire que vous êtes vous
traitez de raciste toute personne qui
critiqueraient parle encore de propos
mois dans comment en de votre chien
encore une fois ça ne me dérangerait
lequel fois je voulais vous répondre
pardon j'oubliais votre prénom mais
trois femmes de ménage ça et qu'elle est
menée ces combats d'ailleurs absolument
vraiment des bons combats et même
qu'elle était le pénis dans le passé je
m'en fiche mais alors complètement oui
c'est à dire qu'elle sait ce qui est
sorti aussi qu'elle ait soutenu marine
le pen dans le passé ce qui se dira m
deux anciens de liberté
pour une fois je bois les paroles de
mathieu et je leur ligne exactement sur
ses propos il ya une différence
à l'aller c'est lui donner les dates de
mykonos assez
du 10 au 21 c'est vrai qu'on peut dire
si elle était en boubou vous regardez et
vous dites moi je trouve que ce n'est
pas la tenue appropriée et ça s'entend
mais là elle n'était pas et donc
directement vous vous la salle et 10 ans
avait heureusement en fin mai mais on
est dans un monde de
susceptibilité dans un monde aux suceurs
tels que j'ai vu we go elle l'était et
alors je constate qu'elle ne l'est pas
et je vais vous en réjouissez vous en
réjouissez je m'engage c'est ça qui est
terrible alors et sakété
racisme je suis prêt s'il voulait même
cinq ans si donc vous voudriez pas par
exemple qu'un député arrive en djellaba
par exemple ah non la meilleure est
tellement pas parce qu'après tout si je
ne voudrais pas
qu'on l'ait l'assemblée nationale doit
doit être des sanctuaires qui vous met
dans la rue et des avais tu la vois que
des miroirs pas d'histoire non
certainement pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]